[Music]
guys if you're anything like me you're
blacksmithing all day you're working
hard hanging out over a hot forge and
all you want to do is come home open up
a cold drink with your boys and just
relax so i'm
going to show you how to do it like a
boss here
like a boss you want a soda
ready
okay guys this trick is really easy all
you're doing is taking your wedding ring
hooking it on the edge of the bottle cap
and then just
boom
you're just rolling your finger over the
top popping off the cap
okay just boom
using that leverage okay
and
the wider your ring
the more comfortable it'll be if you
have a really thin ring it can kind of
dig into your finger a little bit
but this ring right here man it doesn't
hurt at all just pops right off well
some of you guys don't have wedding
rings and sometimes you don't have two
hands to use to open bottle caps and in
that situation
you can do this
oh yeah
there you go
there you go buddy cheers
so you can see here the lip of this cap
is on the top of this one and this one's
on the bottom
so then you just go
like that
off comes
the
bottle oh you guys like that when i
opened it
some water came out
yeah cheers let's head to the playground
cheers
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video